the buses head south towards mariopol
the latest attempt to evacuate thousands
of people trapped in the besieged port
city on the azov sea
mariopol has suffered some of the worst
fighting in recent days
the russian army and russian-backed
separatist fighters have reportedly
surrounded the city
dead bodies lie in the streets
we don't have electricity we don't have
anything to eat we don't have medicine
we've got nothing
everything is mined the roots out of
town are being shelled says the
policeman
at the moment negotiations about leaving
with security have failed trust me i
have family at home and i am also
worried about them he says
unfortunately the best security for us
all is to be inside the city underground
and in shelters
approximately 200 kilometers north in
the town of orokiev the buses meant to
rescue the people of mariopol and
stopped
russian army positions are only 10
kilometers from here
drivers some with family in mariopol
told us they'd heard reports of fighting
on the route
there has been no connection with the
city for days i haven't been able to get
in touch with my wife and sister for
five days we've tried to get to
moriapple twice already this is our
third attempt we don't know if it will
happen
after a more than two hour wait the
convoy coordinator ordered the drivers
to get on the buses and leave
so the buses are now turning round this
after according to the coordinator of
the convoy there are reports of heavy
fighting
on the initially planned route
to marry opel
a group of drivers struggled to start
one of the vehicles
one told us he didn't want to die
we can't go this way because there's
been shelling they won't let us go
through
the checkpoint won't let us go further
because of the shelling we don't know
where we're going now
the convoy headed out of odakiev moving
northeast
another attempt at evacuating thousands
of trapped and terrified people in
mariopol
had failed
charles stratford al jazeera orakiv
eastern ukraine